[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
über dichter und marietta slomka guten
abend kanzler scholz und vizekanzler
habe sind wieder als handelsreisende
unterwegs in sachen energieversorgung
diesmal sogar gemeinsam und mit einem
vergleichsweise sehr angenehmen
reiseziel kanada eine freiheitliche
demokratie mit charmantem
gastgeber-stadt scheichs in katar oder
autoritären herrscher in aserbaidschan
was immer scholz sonntag mit nach hause
bringen man wird ihnen zumindest nicht
vorwerfen dass sie das gas des
kriegsherrn putin durch einkäufe bei
anderen diktatoren ersetzen man fragt
sich nur warum deutschland nicht schon
viel früher eine engere
energiepartnerschaft mit dem
rohstoffreichen kanada angestrebt hat
jan fritsche berichtet
wie wichtig der bundesregierung dieser
besuch ist zeigt sich schon an den
formalien kanzler und vizekanzler reisen
an für ungewöhnlich lange drei tage mit
dabei und ein dutzend hochrangiger
spitzenmanager wie die chefs von
volkswagen und bayer die politische
mission deutschlands energiezukunft
sichern die begrüßung herzlich
danke dass du hier bist olaf olaf ist
eine progressive stimme die in der welt
extrem wichtig ist und ihnen hier in
kanada begrüßen zu dürfen ist eine große
ehre
kanada ist für die deutsche wirtschaft
gleich mehrfach interessant seine
rohstoffe wie lithium werden für die
herstellung von batterien gebraucht
zudem könnte das erdgas reiche land
deutschland lg gas liefern das problem
beim lg fehlt die passende infrastruktur
bis zu einer lieferung nach deutschland
könnte es jahre dauern
mittelfristig setzt die bundesregierung
vor allem auf klimaneutralen grünen
wasserstoff
kanada wird für die entwicklung des
grünen wasserstoffs eine ganz ganz
zentrale rolle spielen und deshalb sind
wir sehr froh dass wir auch bei dieser
gelegenheit unsere kooperation in diesem
feld ausbauen können denn wenn die
erneuerbaren energien eine große rolle
spielen wenn wasserstoff für die zukunft
eine große rolle spielt dann wird kanada
dabei von ganz großer bedeutung weit
über das eigene land hinaus seien auch
beim wasserstoff sind die ersten
lieferungen erst ab 2025 zu erwarten so
wird die energiesituation vorerst
angespannt bleiben doch es geht in
kanada auch um das politische signal
statt wie noch vor monaten bei
zweifelhaften regimen wie katar um hilfe
bei der energieversorgung zu bitten für
die bundesregierung für eine engere
zusammenarbeit der weltweiten
demokratien werden vor allem im
verhältnis zu den autoritären staaten
wie china und russland so wollen die
beiden duzfreunde olaf und justin auch
beim wiederaufbau der ukraine zusammen
arbeiten
putins entscheidung einzumarschieren und
zu versuchen uns zu schwächen hat länder
wie kanada und deutschland dazu gebracht
noch enger zusammenzustehen und noch
vereinter in die zukunft zu blicken
morgen soll die wasserstoff allianz
zwischen beiden ländern besiegelt werden
und auch wenn die maßnahme nicht sofort
wirkt nach tag eins des besuchs steht
fest der ton stimmt beide länder dürften
enger zusammenrücken
theo koll beobachter ist den besuch von
kanzler und vizekanzler in kanada
theorien wir erst mal ganz konkret
darauf sehen bringt uns diese reise
etwas für den winter für unsere hinter
problem hier
ganz konkret gesagt nein es wird uns
nichts und wird uns keine entlastung
bringen weil es noch keine lng terminals
für export lebt in kanada und
wasserstoff da gibt es jetzt ein
abkommen aber die erste wasserstoff wird
dann 2025 erwartet also geht es doch
auch um langfristige perspektiven und um
ein politisches signal oder
absolut und das haben die beiden heute
sehr deutlich gemacht auch
beispielsweise mit blick auf die ukraine
sie haben gesagt dass sie die ukraine
massiv unterstützen werden auch so lange
wie nötig das hat vor allem im trio sehr
deutlich betont sie haben noch mal den
fall der turbine klar gemacht denn bruno
war ja hier im land sehr stark in die
kritik geraten weil er trotz der
sanktionen die turbine ausgeliefert hat
kanzler hat sich dafür ganz besonders
bedankt und beide haben klargemacht dass
haben sie bewusst getan um putins blatt
im grunde offen zu legen dass es nichts
mit dieser turbine zu tun hat dass
russland weniger gas liefert ich finde
insgesamt an diesem besuch hoch
interessant dass kanada im grunde fast
wie ein beispiel ist für die zeit nach
der zeitenwende also die
energiewirtschaft stellt sich ganz neu
auf es werden langfristige
entscheidungen getroffen für grünen
wasserstoff und der kanzler meinte heute
auch noch mal also der schalter ist im
grunde jetzt umgelegt das wird ein ganz
großer teil unserer energiewirtschaft
sein grüner wasserstoff und da ist kann
er da natürlich ganz entscheidend
neufundland wo der kanzler morgen
hinfliegt hat der riesige ressourcen und
wir werden am ende davon auch
profitieren dankeschön theo nach
montreal und
dazu passen schauen wir jetzt nach
russland nicht nur dort schlägt das
attentat auf die tochter des prominenten
ideologen alexander dugin weiter hohe
wellen das kreml-kritiker oder sonstwie
abtrünnigen ex agenten etc tagen
gewaltsam ums leben kommen daran ist man
ja quasi gewohnt aber das glühende kreml
unterstützer und propagandisten ziel
eines gezielten tödlichen anschlags
werden und auch noch auf russischen
boden nahe moskau das gab es bisher so
jedenfalls noch nicht samstag nacht
start daria dorina durch eine autobombe
ob sie selbst oder er ihr vater das ziel
war ist unklar und jetzt gibt es neue
entwicklungen der russische geheimdienst
präsentiert erklärungen außerdem gibt es
ein angebliches bekennerschreiben
andreas kienast berichtet
es sind noch keine 48 stunden vergangen
seit dem mord der russland rätseln lässt
da verkündet das staatsfernsehen
erstaunliches die lösung die mörder von
maria dugena sind ermittelt es war eine
operation ukrainischer geheimdienste
dann zeigt die sendung noch einmal die
sekunden nach dem anschlag das zerfetzte
auto der 29-jährigen das entsetzen im
gesicht ihres vaters originals auto war
am samstagabend explodiert als sie mit
ihrem vater dem rechtsnationalen
ideologen alexander dugin von einer
veranstaltung zurück kamen klar ist frau
dubina ist nicht nur die tochter von
hedging gewesen sie ist selbst eine
rechtsradikale propagandisten die sehr
hart in erscheinung getreten ist ob
china oder ob der vater oder beide das
ziel dieses anschlags waren das kann man
im moment nicht beurteilen daria dugena
galt als fanatische befürworterin des
angriffs auf die ukraine sie rief offen
zur tötung ihrer bewohner auf ukraine
sein um menschen ihr vater alexander
dugin ist ein ultra nationalistische
publizist voller hass auf den westen wie
hier 2016 im zdf-interview support etwas
sagt der westen ist der untergang
europas ich verachte das liberale
bourgeoise europa dieses entartete
politik korrekte pseudo europa
in russland bekennt sich eine bisher
unbekannte gruppe die so genannte
nationale republikanische armee zu dem
anschlag aber der staat widerspricht das
soll die attentäterin sein was russlands
geheimdienst fsb heute über sie an
videos fotos infos verbreitet passt
perfekt die 43 jährige ist angeblich
ukrainerin und angeblich obendrein
mitglied des besonders verhassten asaf
regiments man zeigt ihren ausweis man
zeigt ihren grenzübertritt nach estland
man zeigt sich bemerkenswert zufrieden
sie ist natürlich eine gelungene ein
gelungenes interpretations orangen
einerseits eine ukrainische agentin und
daneben offensichtlich auch noch
gestützt doch ist dann ein staat der im
hinblick auf sanktionen gegen russland
besonders scharf sich artikuliert
innerhalb der europäischen union
in moskau wird estland bereits offen
gedroht und zwar unter anspielung auf
den giftanschlag auf den überläufer
sergej skripal in england die zwei
mutmaßlichen russischen attentäter
hatten damals zu protokoll gegeben nur
die kirchtürme bewundert haben zu wollen
russlands chef propagandisten margarita
simonyan schreibt heute die mörder von
dacia sind bereits in estland ich denke
wir haben profis die türme in der nähe
von tallinn besichtigen wollen ein wort
ein verdacht und der ruf nach vergeltung
ein weiterer konflikt mit dem westen
dabei wurde sprechen mit stefan meister
dem russland experten der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
genannter meister und ein abend sie sind
russlandexperte gucken also auf diese
vorgänge auch noch mal anders nun haben
wir natürlich alle jetzt keine
erkenntnisse ihren tieferen
geheimdienstliche art aber wenn sie sich
das von außen ansehen was steckt
dahinter was glauben sie hinter diesem
attentat
als wir deuten natürlich alle ja weil
wir werden möglicherweise auch in ein
paar jahren nicht wissen wer dann
tatsächlich dahinter steckt aber es gibt
letztlich drei szenarien es kann die
ukraine gewesen sein wie russland das
behauptet es kann diese terroristische
organisation sein die wie das dieser
oppositionspolitiker herr bornemann oft
behauptet oder es ist der fsb selbst
gewesen und meine these wäre er dass das
ein typischer platz für den fsb ist also
es ist doch sehr erstaunlich dass in
diesem überwachten moskau die kameras
mal wieder nicht funktioniert haben als
dieser mord mord passiert ist und das
dann innerhalb von wenigen stunden
ukrainische täterin vom fsb
identifiziert worden ist also das sieht
sehr nach nach diesem platz aus die wir
schon für die anschläge in moskau
am anfang des zweiten tschetschenien
kriegs gesehen haben und dass das
erscheint mir als die wahrscheinlichere
variante von den möglichen bayern was
könnte denn das tiefere end dahinter
sein so eine false flag aktion wie man
das nennt also nun inszeniert das
attentat man immerhin es ist ja doch
eine prominente unterstützerin des kreml
und mehr noch ihr vater
also war muss glaube ich wirklich sehen
dass du ihn so wichtig in moskau dann
auch nicht ist also ich glaube er wird
einfach viel viel wichtiger hier in
teilen eingeschätzt er ist ein wichtiger
ideologe für die eurasische bewegung der
kreml hat einige ideologische elemente
auch genutzt für seine theorien aber du
gehn hat keinen zugang zu putin ja also
dass das ist also der sich würde ich das
mal sagen so wichtig ist du gehn nicht
was ist das interesse also einerseits
kann es natürlich das interesse sein der
ukraine staatsterrorismus vorzuwerfen
also das was die ukraine russland
vorwirft russland ihr jetzt vor und hat
hier eine begründung dafür aber
andererseits kann es darum gehen noch
härter gegen opposition in russland
vorzugehen noch hat er auch gegen
kriegsgegner vorzugehen und im prinzip
diesen plot dazu zu benutzen dass die
opposition hier terroranschläge verübt
oder oder oder eben auch die ukraine
dahinter steckt dafür dann sogar
anhänger sozusagen zu opfern ist ja auch
wegen heftiger gedanke nun gab es ja
dieses ominöse
bekennerschreiben von dieser gruppierung
nationale republikanische armee hat man
glaube ich noch nie von gehört oder
also ich hab noch nie davon gehört ich
beschäftige mich seit 25 jahren mit
russland und dem postsowjetischen raum
ich kenne man oft persönlich auch sehr
gut dass das waren wichtiger oder
relativ wichtige oppositionspolitiker
der schon lange in der ukraine lebt
ukrainische patriot inzwischen geworden
ist aber letztlich auch in der gewissen
bedeutungslosigkeit verschwunden ist
also sehr eigenwillig das klingt für
mich sehr stark nach
verschwörungstheorien und auch dass er
dann da behaupte dass andere anschläge
von dieser gruppe schon verübt worden
sind und noch verübt werden da bin ich
auch sehr sehr skeptisch also es ist
sehr stark verschwörungstheoretiker aber
tatsache ist ja dass in russland auch
zum teil es brandanschläge gab gehäuft
in letzter zeit also dass es auch
irgendwelche formen von sabotage gibt
besteht ja aus ihrer sicht die gefahr
dass ich da etwas gewalttätiges
zusammenbraut innerhalb russlands oder
dass das system putin sogar durch
interne kämpfe implodieren könnte
das glaube ich nicht also ich glaube
dass der sicherheitsapparat ja hier
vorbereitet ist dass es nicht wirklich
eine gefahr gibt für für putin im
gegenteil man könnte sogar die theorie
vertreten dass das im prinzip jeden
treffen kann wenn es du ihn treffen kann
kann es auch jeden im system treffen das
könnte auch eine nachricht sozusagen des
fsb sein oder auch des regimes dass man
eben diese person jetzt geopfert hat um
allen zu zeigen dass sie wenn sie nicht
loyal sind sie ist auch jederzeit
treffen kann interessanter gedanke lag
der meister dank für das gespräch und
die einschätzung sehr gerne
das interview vor zwei stunden geführt
mehr hintergründe zum anschlag in
russland und generell zu russlands krieg
gegen die ukraine finden sie bei uns wie
immer online auf zdf heute und mit den
wirtschaftlichen folgen des kriegs für
uns und den sozialen härten die damit
einhergehen geht es jetzt in den
nachrichten weiter keine sollte ja
angesichts der hohen preise wächst die
sorge vor einer gesellschaftlichen
spaltung
entsprechend werden die rufe lauter
gezielt menschen mit geringem einkommen
zu entlasten
so sagte wirtschaftsminister harwig im
zdf es sei wichtig den demokratischen
grundkonsens zu erhalten indem man einen
sozialen ausgleich schaffen ähnlich
äußerte sich der sozialpolitische
sprecher der unionsfraktion stracke in
der rheinischen post forderte er rasche
hilfen auch für rentner und studierende
angesichts der extremen trockenheit
fordert der städte und gemeindebund
klare gesetzliche regeln für die
trinkwasser nutzung hauptgeschäftsführer
rheinsberg sagte der rheinischen post
bei engpässen brauche es verbindliche
vorgaben wessen wasserverbrauch zuerst
rationiert wird die öffentliche
versorgung zb für privathaushalte müsse
dabei stets vorrang haben
die abgerufene rbb-intendantin patricia
schlesinger wird fristlos entlassen das
hat der verwaltungsrat des senders
beschlossen die 61 jährige erhält nun
weder abfindung noch ruhegeld ihre
anwälte sprechen von einer politisch
motivierten entscheidung gegen
schlesinger läuft ein
ermittlungsverfahren wegen des verdachts
der untreue und vorteilsnahme
israels neuer botschafter in deutschland
hat heute sein amt angetreten ron prosor
erhielt im schloss bellevue seine
ernennungsurkunde von bundespräsident
steinmeier sein neuer posten sei ihm ein
tiefes persönliches anliegen sagte der
63 jährige bei einer rede auf dem
bebelplatz dem ort der bücherverbrennung
von 1933
im selben jahr für sein vater vor den
nationalsozialisten
ressort war bereits botschafter in
großbritannien und bei der uno
mehr als zwei jahre lang waren auf den
philippinen die schulen geschlossen
wegen der korona pandemie nun können die
schülerinnen und schüler endlich zurück
unter ihnen mehr als 28 millionen die
heute zum ersten mal im klassenzimmer
saßen allerdings bieten viele schulen
vorerst nur wechsel unterricht an schon
vor der pandemie galt das bildungsniveau
im internationalen vergleich als niedrig
und dann blicken wir noch in eine andere
welt region nach südamerika kolumbien
dort ist gerade die deutsche
entwicklungsministerin zu besuch in
einem land das sich schon vor jahren
aufgemacht hat seine blutige
vergangenheit hinter sich zu lassen das
nicht mehr mit bürgerkrieg guerilla und
kokain kartellen assoziiert werden will
doch in den verwüstungen die all das
angerichtet hat trägt kolumbien bis
heute schwer
und dann kommt noch ein hoch
problematischer nachbar hin zu venezuela
das sind gewalt und armut versinkt
millionen menschen sind in den letzten
jahren von dort geflüchtet und ein
großteil kommt über die grenze nach
kolumbien christoph röck zeigt wie das
land damit umgeht
es ist das erste konzert von louis in
kolumbien seine mutter mora ist
überwältigt für beide ein moment in dem
sie ihre würde wieder finden
wochenlang haben sie auf den straßen von
bogotá ums überleben gekämpft bis hier
in dieser hilfseinrichtung ein dach über
dem kopf gefunden haben ein kind bedankt
sich bei einem ganzen land
[Applaus]
danke an alle in kolumbien für diese
möglichkeit für die möglichkeit dass ich
hier einwandern durften
keine 50 kilo wog louis vater manuel als
er sich vor knapp drei wochen mit seiner
familie in die flüchtlingsunterkunft
schleppte
dank der einrichtung dank des essens
hier sagt seine frau cora geht es ihm
schon viel besser wie ihr seht hat er
sogar etwas zugenommen dass die menschen
wieder auf eigenen beinen stehen können
auch langfristig ist das ziel der
einrichtung und ein grund warum sich von
deutschland und der eu gefördert wird
entwicklungsministerin svenja schulze
will sich ein bild machen von den
maßnahmen die die integration fördern
sollen vor allem die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen in kolumbien sieht sie
als vorbildlich an auch für deutschland
hier bekommt jeder registrierte
geflüchtete mensch zehn jahre die
möglichkeit einen beruf zu finden die
kinder können in die schule gehen der
zugang zur gesundheitsversorgung ist
geregelt und das ist breit akzeptiert in
der gesellschaft und ich wünsche mir
dass wir auch in deutschland mit
geflüchteten menschen großzügiger
umgehen als wir das in der vergangenheit
getan haben wie das funktionieren kann
zeigt sich an vielen stellen in bogotá
jeden morgen fährt rossi antonio mit
seinem zum benziner umgebauten fahrrad
zur arbeit vor anderthalb jahren
flüchtete er von venezuela nach
kolumbien und hat hier in einer bäckerei
einen festen job gefunden auch seine
chefin jenny ist vor einigen jahren aus
venezuela geflohen und hat es sich zur
aufgabe gemacht ihren landsleuten zu
helfen
mit einem regelmäßigen einkommen erhält
nur stabilität du machst dir nicht mehr
so viele sorgen du musst keine angst
mehr haben dass du nicht genug zu essen
wie du deine miete bezahlt oder video an
medikamente kommst wenn du krank wirst
und wer arbeitet zahlt auch steuern
davon profitiert der staat für louis
aurora und ihre familie aber ist es bis
dahin noch ein weiter weg jeden morgen
verlassen sie die unterkunft um einen
job zu finden doch oft bleibt ihnen
nichts anderes als auf der straße zu
betteln
die europäische union diskutiert aktuell
ja über die visavergabe an russische
touristen dann lohnt sich aber auch
näher hin zu sehen wie manche eu
mitgliedsländer in den letzten jahren
europäische pässe vergeben haben und
damit geht es jetzt bei kaiser noch
arbeiter ja so hat zypern offenbar
tausende illegale staatsbürgerschaften
vergeben das zeigt ein
untersuchungsbericht der zuständigen
kontrollbehörde des landes es handele
sich um sogenannte goldene pässe die man
für mindestens zweieinhalb millionen
euro kaufen konnte die empfänger dürfen
sich damit frei im schengen raum bewegen
unter ihnen waren laut medienberichten
auch russische oligarchen denen die
pässe aber wieder entzogen worden sein
ab oktober wird ja die gasanlage fällig
mit der energie unternehmen vor der
insolvenz geschützt werden sollen
versorger die davon profitieren wollen
mussten sich dafür anmelden und zwölf
haben das fristgerecht getan heißt das
denn stefanie wäre dass alle auch geld
aus der umlage bekommen also ein
großteil der milliarden schweren gas
umlage entfällt tatsächlich nur auf drei
unternehmen zwei drittel der insgesamt
34 milliarden euro die für die gasse
umlage bis 2024 anfallen fließen auf das
konto von juniper das eben voll auf
russisches gas gesetzt hatte und auch
wegen seiner umfangreichen beteiligung
an nordstream 2 in finanzielle
schieflage geraten ist und 25 prozent
gehen an das nachfolgeunternehmen von
gazprom germania safe und die ndw
tochter vng weitere unternehmen haben
sich vorsorglich listen lassen darunter
auch der energiekonzern rwe der
vergangene woche eigentlich angekündigt
hatte keine gelder in anspruch nehmen zu
wollen weil das unternehmen derzeit mit
seinem strom- und gashandel gute gewinne
erzielt nun schlüpft man also doch
sicherheitshalber unter den
rettungsschirm der gasanlage um sich für
alle fälle zu wappnen die
energieversorger fürchten nämlich
lieferengpässe und weiter steigende
kosten allein gazproms ankündigung einer
neuen liga pause nächste woche lässt den
gaspreis um weitere 23 prozent nach oben
schießen das dürfte auch die teuerung
weiter anheizen dieser mix aus
steigenden energiepreisen und inflation
verschreckte hier zu wochenbeginn pont
die anleger und schickte den dax mit
über 300 punkten oder 2,3 prozent auf
talfahrt im lichte aktueller sorgen von
gaskunden ist dieses dicke - aber wohl
eher verschmerzbar
aufwärts geht es dagegen am rhein der
führt nach dem regen der vergangenen
tage wieder etwas mehr wasser bis zum
frühen morgen erhöhte sich der
pegelstand bei coop auf 100 zentimeter
40 mehr als gestern morgen gilt als
nadelöhr der rheinschifffahrt weil der
fluss dort besonders flach ist experten
warten erwarten allerdings dass die
wasserstände schon bald wieder sinken
die gletscher in der schweiz haben in
nur 85 jahren die hälfte ihres eises
verloren das zeigt eine studie für die
wissenschaftler mehr als 20.000 fotos
ausgewertet haben dabei verglichen sie
die jahre 1931 und 2016 inzwischen habe
sich die gletscherschmelze sogar noch
beschleunigt allein in den vergangenen
sechs jahren seien noch einmal zwölf des
eises verschwunden
er hat die zeit über viele jahre
maßgeblich mitgeprägt nun ist der
journalist theo sommer gestorben
1958 kam sommer zu der hamburger
wochenzeitung wurde 15 jahre später dort
chefredakteur bis er in die herausgeber
funktion wechselte unter anderem neben
altkanzler schmidt auch im hohen alter
hatte theo sommer noch ein büro im
verlagshaus er wurde 92 jahre alt
das freibad für manche ein genuss für
andere ein horror hängt wohl auch vom
jeweiligen bart ab auf jeden fall das
freibad ist an und für sich ein
institution mehr noch ein soziales
biotop in dem zwischenmenschliches immer
wieder neu verhandelt wird bis hin zu
ernsthaften
gesellschaftspolitischen debatten
private ist auch der titel des neuen
kinofilms von doris dörrie der nächste
woche bei uns anläuft eine kumulieren
inspiriert wurde sie dazu von einem real
existierenden freibad im breisgau ein
reines frauenbad da sollte es manche
konflikte doch gar nicht erst geben
könnte man meinen aber weit gefehlt
unsere filmkritikerin sabine schulz hat
sich das freibad bereits angesehen
ein freibad nur für frauen die damenwelt
unter sich hier kann frau tun und lassen
was sie will naja fast
die ist doch total fremd gesteuert in
den denk für die eigentlich kannst
exchange waren gabi sammelt dafür auf
die straße gegangen
es ist dort habe ich aus es geht um
fragen des miteinanders wie tolerant
sind wir wirklich erst recht als eine
gruppe burkini frauen das damenbad für
sich entdeckt die verschleierung ist
eine attacke auf uns in unserer kultur
zeigt man sein gesicht die story basiert
auf wahren begebenheiten in einem
freiburger frauen freibad doch toy story
geht es um mehr
es geht eigentlich bei dieser metapher
freibad um demokratie wie wir zusammen
die regeln wieder neu verhandeln können
und ich glaube das müssen wir weil es
natürlich für unser land steht dieses
kleine freibad wo jeder seite des mains
und ich bestimme die regel
leider nichts machen ein klischees und
vorurteile auf dem prüfstand kleine
alltägliche rassismen aber es gibt auch
überraschende perspektivwechsel
[Musik]
wissen flüchtling ist die schweiz
luxemburg und lothringen in der schweiz
stossen auf
foto roswitha frey es ist so schön dass
ihr euren freie partie und für mich war
das freibad ort der seligkeit als kind
und dann hole ich teenager und plötzlich
wurde ich sehr sehr schüchtern und war
mir sehr meines körpers bewusst und dann
cups auch ganz schnell kommentare von
jungs aber auch von frauen über meinen
körper und da geht er der rakete das
findest du jetzt lustig die urteile die
ständige bewertung des weiblichen
körpers auch das ist thema dieses films
und diese urteile die sitzen oft sehr
sehr tief und wenn man mal nachfragt
dann hat jeder einzelne von uns so ein
urteil über sich im kopf aus dem
beschenkten bodyshaping optimierungs war
ein sehr weiblicher blick eine
sommerkomödie mit witz und biss
[Musik]
eigentlich genug
wenn auch manchmal recht überdreht
weniger wäre mehr gewesen
alles ein bisschen zu viel auch für die
bademeisterin kündigen ist dieser mann
toll dass wir dich so schnell gefunden
haben der neue bademeister ist ein mann
freibad ist eben nicht nur ein
frauenfilm beim filmfest münchen war das
publikum begeistert
ein film den man gemeinsam sehen muss
ein illustres ensemble und jede menge
gesprächsstoff gibt es allemal
oder im kino
im zdf jedenfalls vielleicht erst mal im
kino im montagskino da beginnt heute die
neue thriller serie the tourist duell im
outback und
außerdem empfehlen wir ihnen doch das
heute-journal update um 0.8 da spricht
wohl schmiedel mit entspannt
[Musik]
guten abend ja haben sie das auch
gemerkt am samstag überquerte
deutschland eine kaltfront dahinter war
es wirklich deutlich kühler allerdings
brachte diese kaltfront meist nur
punktuell kräftige schauer nicht mehr
geregnet hat es in sachsen bayern und in
baden württemberg und auch heute fielen
noch regen das hängt zusammen mit diesem
tiefen nicole dass uns auch morgen von
osten wolken und regen trägt das
hochbeet dagegen wird morgen richtung
skandinavien also nordwärts abziehen und
das -tief minister über den britischen
inseln bringt aus südwesteuropa noch mal
sehr hohe temperaturen zu uns nach
mitteleuropa in frankreich und in
spanien liegen morgen die werte schon
bei 30 35 grad unter dem tiefen nicole
bleibt es kühler wird nur so 20 grad und
heute nacht sinken die temperaturen in
bayern auf 12 bis 8 grad sonst bleibt
die nacht milder bei 17 bis 13 grad die
nacht auf donnerstag aber könnte schon
wieder tropisch werden also mit
nachttemperaturen die nicht unter 20
grad sinken heute nacht fällt hier im
osten noch etwas regen im südwesten ist
es dagegen klar und an dieser wetter
verteilung ändert sich auch morgen über
tag wenig im westen quellwolken und
zwischen der lübecker bucht und dem
bodensee zeigt sich häufig die sonne im
osten ist es dagegen stärker bewölkt und
dort fällt regen und da liegen dann die
temperaturen morgen auch nur bei etwa 19
bis 24 grad richtung westen ist es
wärmer besonders im rhein main gebiet
wird es heißen bis zu 32 grad der
mittwoch wird bei uns trocken sein aber
ab donnerstag kommen dann von osten
einige gewitter haben damit wünsche ich
ihnen einen schönen abend